Around a week ago, this brilliant
individual made a comment under my video
asking for me to find ineffective
suggestions by EDH. And I thought it was
an excellent idea, but I wasn't sure if
I'd be able to find enough good examples
for an entire video. After all, decks on
EDH Wreck, especially those top
commanders, are checked by thousands of
people every day. There's no way garbage
can stick around for long.
[Music]
Guess we're making the video. Hello
everyone, this is Next Level Commander
and today we are going over examples of
EDHR recommending truly terrible cards
for some of the most popular commanders.
Some of them are overhyped, some are
outdated, and the last two don't even
work. And this isn't just a memes list,
but rather I'd like to look a little
deeper into the nuances of card
evaluation. Let's go. First card comes
from the second most popular commander
of all time, the Dragon. And this is a
classic example when talking about card
evaluation, Crucible of Fire. It is in
over 8,000 decks and at least five other
YouTube videos talking about why it's
not good. Dragons you control get plus
three plus three. Now, the easiest way
to see the misleading part of this card
is imagining it just being an
enchantment that gives plus three to
everything to all your creatures. That
would be a great card. It would see play
in tons of tokens and goblins text, but
likely won't get a second look from most
dragon players. Our thoughts are blocked
by the dragon specific rules text. And
as soon as the block is lifted, it's not
hard for us to see that crucible of fire
is wind. If you have enough dragons for
the pump to be meaningful, you're
winning the game with or without it
anyways. And if the dragon text alone
isn't enough to shut off our judgment
completely, seeing it on the top of the
EDHC page gets it done. And this is the
problem with this site. It is not that
we are incapable of analyzing. It's just
that that part of the brain is shut off
when we browse EDHREC. I don't mind us.
Reminds me of the countless number of
times I drove into an obvious dead end
following my GPS. Next up is a card in
Calia. And the suspect here is a Chroma
Angel of Wrath. Now, 15 years ago, this
might have made sense, but nowadays a
Chroma just doesn't cut it anymore with
all the crazy bombs being released left
and right. I mean, dropping this with
Calia, congratulations. You just don
someone for six when it could have been
10, 12, or six, but with 15 treasures
added on. I believe that some are misled
by the manacost thinking the more you
cheat, the more you save. But in a Calia
deck, it's actually really important to
also have plans for when your commander
gets removed. Rightfully, imagine paying
eight mana to hard cast this in
2025. With that in mind, even a bane
slayer angel is probably a better choice
overall. However, saying all this, I'm
neglecting one of the biggest polls of
Acroma. It is one of the most iconic
angels. Heck, even one of the most
iconic creatures in the history of
Magic, and people play her for that
nostalgia. That is cool. I get it. But
this brings up another problem with
Idiot Wreck. In a format that is driven
by so many different motivations besides
just winning the game, it's impossible
for us to know which ones are behind the
card choices displayed here. And
therefore, it is difficult for deck
builders, especially those with less
experience, to take that into
consideration. At this point, I really
hope EDHR doesn't send me a sponsorship
offer or I'm going to look real
hypocritical. Anyways, moving on to
Euro. And the card here is Shadow of
Immortality in over 61% of Euro decks. I
get it. I get it. It's 15 damage when
you flip it with Euro, but what's the
chance of you flipping it? Oh, yeah. You
can tutor for it with your game changer,
vampiric tutor. So, let's take a closer
look at the card that we're tutoring for
with our game changer just to do that
little bit of extra
damage. We have a 15 mana,
vanilla. And if you're at 27 life or
lower, it's two mana. Wow. Two mana, 77.
When you have a decent board with Euro
triggering, are you sure you don't want
to search for some kind of finisher?
Roaming Throne, perhaps? Sure. is
dealing far less damage on the trigger
itself, but getting those triggers
doubled in the future will close out the
game faster than the shade, I promise.
Or if you're worried about your board
getting answered, how about a counter
spell that also deals 10 damage. Now,
let's take a look at a few more other
cards that not only does decent damage,
but also doesn't do close to nothing if
you happen to draw them. So, as you can
see, just getting that 15 damage once in
a while feels good. And so does hitting
your opponents for 100 damage rather
than 80 with Crucible Fire. But balance
and consistency will make your average
game more enjoyable and effective. Next
up, Giata.
66% over 13,000 players are playing this
card. Youthful
Valkyrie. I don't I don't know what to
say, man. This is We are getting worse
with every card. I mean, look at this
card. It's a two- mana angel that gets
slightly bigger every turn. That's it.
Okay, let's put ourselves in the shoes
of a Giata player.
Now imagine we are playing kiata like we
always wanted to. We are in bracket one
because bracket zero doesn't exist. We
draw our opening hand. Nice youthful
Valkyrie. This is what low drops are
for. Turn one. Turn two. Finally I can
tap two mana for
Kiata. Yeah, that's the play. It's okay.
Next turn. Wait, but next turn we have
four mana. Are we going to play this
over the four drop
angels? We may not have a four drop, you
say? Yes, because this youthful Valkyrie
should be a four
drop. Okay, wake
up. We are mono white. We are fighting
uphill from turn one. And here you be
playing this two mana do nothing like
you have a blue sun zenith for 12 lined
up. Just
don't. Okay. And if you're thinking it
can't get worse from here, it absolutely
can. Now we're stepping into cards that
don't actually work territory. Nekusar
days undo. I know it's only 14%, but
that's still 3,000 decks too many. This
card does nothing. Yes, it's a time
twister. Yeah, it's sick. Everyone is
excited. But why are we time twistering
again? Oh yeah, for the triggers, the
damage, the locust tokens. Except I
gotta remind you to read days undoing's
reminder text if the name wasn't warning
enough. Oh, and the 894 Cyrus players. I
didn't forget about you guys either. You
guys can't even play notion thief.
That's like the one card that works with
this duel. But it's okay. We are not at
the bottom just yet. Next up, we have a
card that's literally worse than a basic
land. Juladoc Marriott landscape 2000
decks. Marriott landscape searches for
two basic lands. Uh, no problem. We got
wastes that share a land type. Oh, okay.
To be fair, this is kind of fringe. It's
very technical. I just learned about
this a few hours ago when doing research
for this video, and now I turn it around
to make fun of you. Funny how life works
sometimes. But yeah, cut this from your
colorless text. Don't play this. And
now, time for the worst EDH wreck fail
that I was able to find today. a card
that actively shuts down your commander.
Bernard Ginger Sculptor and his academy
manufacturer in
37% 3,585 decks. Bernard turns your
dying creatures into food, a really
powerful ability. An economy recctor
tacks on a treasure and a clue, but
actually it doesn't exactly tack on.
That's where people are misled. What's
not to love here is the word instead.
Yes, Academy director creates a new food
token and overrides Bernard's ability.
So, it's just food. I guess if you want
to exchange your Mandra or triplicate
Titan for a clue and a treasure token,
it's cool, but I'm pretty sure you
don't. This card literally shuts down
your commander, which I assume your
entire deck is built around, so please
take it out. Do not play Academy
Manufacturer. And that wraps it up. I
realize I've been mentioning ED track a
lot lately. I'm not a hater, I promise.
I also enjoy taking a list and playing
it immediately, especially for the
tribal decks. But still, these memew
worthy errors are decent reminders for
us and myself to just turn on our brains
just a little when handed card
suggestions and deck lists by EDHR. Do a
little bit of system two thinking
between your Cheetos and Mountain Dew
sips. It will make us better deck
builders. I promise. So yeah, thank you
for watching. Please like, subscribe,
and comment. Let me know what you want
to see in the future. That's all. I'll
see you in the next video.